[Music]
Karl Marx is often described as one of
the greatest thinkers of the 19th
century his writings have inspired
revolutions and generated centuries of
fierce debate born in Prussia now
Germany in May 1818 Marx believed that
capitalism which was in its infancy at
the time had serious flaws Marx claimed
that in pursuit of profit capitalists
would encourage their ideology that work
is good leisure is bad and material
things will make us happy embracing mass
production depriving workers of job
satisfaction at the same time exploiting
the working-class he became involved in
the communist League a small group of
intellectuals who wanted to abolish the
class system and spread wealth equally
Marx wrote the communist manifesto in
1847 with his benefactor Friedrich
Engels laying out the Marxist vision of
a society where wealth was distributed
evenly property is owned publicly and
education is free for all but Marx was
little known and little read at the time
when he died in 1883 only eleven people
attended his funeral after his death his
ideas flourished based on the theory of
Marxism came communism the realization
of a stateless society where all are
equal communism became a global movement
but the utopian ideal of a fair and
equal society failed to materialize
communism terrorized and impoverished
its subjects and slaughtered them in the
tens of millions today capitalism
dominates the world but many of Marx's
criticisms have never been more relevant
today the global disparity between rich
and poor is striking Marx predicted that
capitalism
would lead to the rich getting richer
and the poor staying Paul he was right
he also predicted that capitalism would
lead to boom and bust economics Marx
predicted that capitalism would lead to
globalization and that a handful of
firms would have huge market dominance
[Music]
however Marx underestimated the ability
of capitalism to make everybody richer
by making products much cheaper since
the 1980s the number of people in
absolute poverty has fallen by about 1
billion he also got wrong the capacity
of capitalism to reform itself by
creating welfare states that
redistributed wealth through taxation
although there is a lot to learn from
Marx his solution was far worse than the
disease at the same time it can't be
said that today's capitalism dominated
by immense inequality and financial
crises has triumphed
[Music]
you